what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are continuing on with Earth
x and again I god I love this story so
much we're about half way through right
now both humming in this video will be
about a little over halfway through um
this is such a cool story I love Earth X
so much because it's it's interesting
I'm still debating on whether or not I'm
gonna do universe X and paradise X I'm
still not sure yet but what we do in
this video is we initially pick up with
the origin of the Incredible Hulk in
Earth X and for the most part this
origin story is almost identical to the
origin that exists inside Marvel Comics
with one major difference now of course
that the whole idea of like Bruce Banner
having been a genius and then going on
to basically develop the gamma bomb
that's all still intact the difference
here is that in Marvel in the main
Marvel continuity the idea was that
Bruce Banner had these different forms
of the whole quote-unquote because they
represented different facets of his
personality you had like Joe fix-it who
was the mobster Hulk you had like devil
hook different things like that in Earth
X that's not the case instead they're
just evolutions of the same being the
idea is that inside of Bruce Banner is
this gamma radiation that's constantly
growing and constantly expanding what
the gamma radiation is trying to do is
leave the body of Bruce Banner and
manifest itself physically and that's
what takes place what ends up happening
here is Bruce Banner any Incredible Hulk
basically split and that's why you have
two distinctly different people here you
have Bruce Banner and then you have the
Incredible Hulk again the caveat to all
this is that Bruce Banner sees through
the eyes of the Incredible Hulk now
again this all ties into the ongoing
events of what's taking place with
regards to banner and Clea and so on but
before we jump back into that I do want
to kind of pick up with this next little
transition which deals with Reed
Richards looking for cerebro now again
cerebro of course is the helmet used by
Charles Xavier that was designed for the
purpose of locating mutants but because
the x-men to funked for really a number
of years and because Xavier himself is
basically dead what this means is that
the cerebral helmets just kind of been
out there now under normal circumstances
that helmet can only be used by those
who have telepathic powers Reed Richards
doesn't have those and so the question
is how is he going to be able to pull
this off now what he does is he actually
goes to see Ben Grimm and the reason for
this is because Ben Grimm basically has
within his I guess really within like a
place that Rita built for him these
various schematics of Charles Xavier is
brain and Reed Richards is looking for
this because what he can do is basically
quote unquote
modify his own brain to basically match
that of Charles Xavier and kind of give
off this perception that he has
telepathy now this is really just kind
of things going fast and loose with
regards to like Reed Richards powers I
mean Ridge right Reed Richards doesn't
really have telepathy but the idea was
that he could basically kind of trick
cerebro into believing that he does and
so we just kinda have to roll with it
we're just gonna have to roll with it
for what it is but before we find out
the conclusion that he comes to which is
a pretty major one what we end up doing
is jumping directly back to the
Incredible Hulk and CLIA now remember
CLIA is the niece of Dormammu but in
Marvel Comics she was basically the
apprentice and really the lover of
Doctor Strange for quite some time the
difference here is that in the earth X
line of comics dr. Strange's spiritual
essence is basically dead and his body's
just there or at least it's believed his
spiritual essence is dead and his body's
just kind of sitting there at the same
time Bruce Banner had a dream that came
from Captain Marvel that the world was
going to end and so that's why they're
traveling into the realm of mistress
death again if you want to know that
know more about that in a little more
detail the last video of flesh all that
stuff out well they're basically going
into the realm of mistress death to find
Marvel and asked him the question why
did you appear to me in a dream and why
are you telling me the world is ending
and so once the Incredible Hulk goes
into the realm of mistress death as a
tether of sorts what this means is it
allows us to basically see what goes on
inside this world and this is kind of
ironic because in the land of the dead
the heroes who were there don't know
they're dead instead they're still
continuing on to fight like they always
did now notice this it's not a cuddle
but fight the way we would expect it
which is to say like the x-men fighting
an x-men villain and the Fantastic Four
fighting a Fantastic Four villain or at
least what's left of the Fantastic Four
is just heroes fighting bad guys and so
they're just kind of caught in this
eternal struggle of good guys versus bad
guys and this is what they do but
because of the fact of the heroes don't
know they're dead they're just
continuing on the same way they always
did and it's kind of cool to see these
small little things here and there you
know for example a Susan storm and
Johnny Storm are looking for Reed
Richards and Ben Grimm because they
don't know they're dead now ultimately
we end up having the Incredible Hulk in
a search for Marvel who basically
travels to the realm of Doctor Strange
in this kind of Land of the Dead version
of New York and then comes across the
spirit the essence of Doctor Strange
which is passed on to the dead and
Doctor Strange silly just says hey look
there's a lot going on here that you
don't know about I don't have time to
tell you everything but the person that
you see is Loki the individual that you
would call Loki is not as devious as you
believe he is
said like he's going to be one of the
people who's supposed to help things the
problem with this is he's allied himself
with someone evil thought before the
Incredible Hulk can find out what it is
we basically end up just sort of
transitioning back to Bruce Banner and
this is when we start to go through
everything that's going on because what
ends up taking place is Bruce Banner
really kind of calls out and says hey
look things are getting kind of hairy in
here ultimately like Thor jumps in now
it's really Bruce Banner putting on a
ruse right I mean dr. strange tells the
Incredible Hulk
really tells Banner through the eyes of
the Hulk do not tell anyone that you're
talking to me right now no one can know
you're talking to me and the reason for
this is because the death of dr. strange
came at the hands of Clea she killed her
own master she basically destroyed his
spiritual essence and the reason for
this is because she turned her back on
Doctor Strange
and allied herself with Loki so like
it's pretty intense and pretty hardcore
and it is pretty interesting but what
were you not doing at this point is
jumping directly to Captain America
because again inside the city of Los
Angeles you basically had a young kid
called the skull and this kid
essentially had the power to dominate
the minds of others cast illusions
different things like that
basically bend them to his whim and the
result is that he's been massive in
amassing an army that's about 10,000
strong and where Captain America had
sent out these few mutants that he
discovered here and there to basically
go receive training from from Cyclops
they've been banding together in Captain
America's basically been building an
army under the auspices that when you
end up having the scroll and his forces
who show up in New York that uh Captain
America is gonna be able to take them on
with his own gathering of source now one
thing to bear in mind here it's not like
the skull is showing up to New York with
an army of like 10,000 super-powered
people it's not really like that I said
it's just an army of 10,000 people and
so there are a lot of super-powered
beings there but just because people
have powers doesn't mean they have even
power so really the scales could kind of
go either way the benefit for the for
the skull is that at the end of the day
the good guys will try to hurt innocent
people and that's where the villains
will ultimately end up coming out on top
and the various skirmishes and the
conflicts that we've seen over the
course of Marvel Comics history now at
this point we jump directly to the
origin of Peter Parker spider-man and
again this origin falls very much in
line in the same way it starts to give
us this origin of Peter Parker who
gained his powers from a radioactive
spider bite ultimately he fell in love
with with with Gwen Stacy Uncle Ben died
Peter Parker had his whole history Gwen
Stacy eventually died in the night when
Stacy died storyline and then of course
he goes on to marry Mary Jane Watson now
basically of course their whole
situation comes to an end but it also
hits on things like
Peter Parker getting the Venom symbiote
during the original Secret Wars from
1984 and that explains how the venom
simian is here on earth so again all
these histories are still pretty much
the exact same the difference is that in
this story we end up basically picking
up with John Jameson showing up to the
two people who have been analyzing this
the entire time now that's why I wanted
to kind of hold off and basically offer
this explanation on who these guys are
what we have here is essentially who
watch you The Watcher and machine man
now Machine Man made his debut back in
1977 with 2001 a Space Odyssey issue
number 8 and that was actually a line of
comics if I remember correctly and got
him that's one of those like really
obscure line of comics that's one of
those concepts that I believe was like
thought up and it was written and drawn
by Jack Kirby it was like his own solo
thing outside of like the influence of
Stan Lee or anybody else but when it
comes to like Aaron's stack he is the
son of a guy named dr. Abel stack and an
issue number 8 what we found out was
that there were a group of scientists
who are basically trying to create super
soldiers of source but they were
creating robots that would become
soldiers and the journal gist of this
was that they would in turn basically be
sent out through all through all of
humanity and nobody would know they
existed because nobody would be able to
tell the difference between them and
regular people so think like terminators
more or less the issue with this was
that about 50 Evinrude there were 51
that were commissioned and the other 50
were destroyed yes X 1 through 50 were
completely annihilated by the by the
scientists themselves due to the fact
that the robots began to display traits
that indicated that they were
essentially going insane now the reason
why Aaron stack didn't go crazy is
because Abel stack actually took him
home and then treated him like a person
raised him like a human being and by
virtue of receiving this sort of
extrasensory input on being perceived as
a human Aaron stock began to perceive
himself as a human and so is basically
just taking in all the sensory
information and then assimilating it
into his own programming and that's the
difference between Abel stack and the
other or the other x50 robots is the
other x50 robots didn't have human
stimulus and so when they were basically
assigned the programming task of your
job is to protect humanity they wouldn't
really know how to function accordingly
they would just eventually start to go
insane because their programming
couldn't account for the orders they
were given with how they reconcile those
orders and so I where he's really one of
the more obscure characters in Marvel
Comics what ended up happening in this
story is Aaron stack was basically
whisked away to the moon by
walk to the watcher and who want to
basically went to Aaron and said you are
going to become the new watcher and I'm
going to teach you how to be a watcher
by showing you everything that's going
on on earth and you're going to look
into the past of everything and you're
going to compare it to what's going on
now and your spin you're basically going
to learn to understand humanity you're
gonna understand humanity on a much
greater scale than you currently do and
so that's what's been happening the two
of them have basically been looking at
everything that's been going on and
we've essentially been getting like the
history of the Marvel Universe in Earth
X by virtue of these two now the other
half of this is that as Aaron stack had
been watching everything that was going
on and learning all this information
he'd been simultaneously downloading all
these back logs and all these catalogs
essentially everything who watches The
Watcher had stored even though hoo-wah -
didn't really tell him - so from a lot
to his mindset he was talking to a robot
that had an understanding of humanity
but didn't really have a personality per
se he was basically a blank slate but
Aaron stack is not a blank slate he had
curiosity he has anger he has rage he
has love and you know jealousy and
affection and different things like that
and so the result is that he's basically
learned that who watches The Watcher is
harboring a secret that there's
something going on here behind the
scenes that hoo-wah to knows about that
Aaron stack himself intends to try to
end so it's almost like all these
different roads are sort of converging
into the same place now in the midst of
all this of course John Jameson shows up
and says look there's a massive ship
headed this way and like it looks like
it's powerful enough to obliterate the
earth I have no idea what this means or
what it's going to do but before we end
up jumping into all that we basically go
back to what it is that's taking place
on earth and we essentially pick up with
the forces of the skull showing up in
New York and basically attacking
everybody that they come across now this
is really more of like a hey we're here
we're conquering everything those who
disagree will be dealt with they'll be
you know either they'll be brought under
my control
or they'll be destroyed and then we'll
just kind of expand our sphere of
influence and where Captain America
shows up to the residents of Tony Stark
the argument he makes here is really
really intriguing the idea of him
showing up is saying hey look man like
you're part of this just like anybody
else you have to get involved but
remember Tony Stark is kind of removed
he's isolated from humanity he just kind
of serves the purpose of trying to keep
things in order as well as trying to
make sure that like the global global
supplies are kept in check and
everything else just kind of exists out
there and so really everything outside
of whatever it is that Norman Osborn
cares about and whatever it is Tony
Stark cares about it's just kind of no
man
it's just kind of like you know the land
of do as you please maybe you'll survive
maybe you won't but that's not my
problem
now again were the forces of New York
stemming off this attack as best they
can the school's ability to like
dominate the minds of others is seen in
a multitude of ways for example the cops
that are with with you know sergeant
Luke Cage are forced to turn on Luke
Cage but of course you know Cage has
unbreakable skin and so the bullets they
used to try to shoot him with don't
really work made a Parker the daughter
of Peter Parker who jumps into the Frank
now here's kind of the funny thing here
maybe Parker again is currently in
possession of the Venom symbiote we
talked about that when it came to the
whole thing that's constant what Peter
Parker says is like you had the Venom
symbiote you have to learn how to
control yourself but ultimately she's
kind of young and headstrong and jumping
into it all now we will find out was a
little more than what's going on here
but it is cool to kind of see this thing
take place Peter Parker trying to impart
his pearls of wisdom onto his daughter
at the same time we have our Reed
Richards who's again get hidden to
analyze everything that's going on and
Reed Richards begins to come to the
conclusion or he begins to look around
after modifying the helmet of Charles
Xavier and comes to the realization
these guys the people who are walking
around earth they're not mutants they're
Inhumans now again this story was
written long before the events of the of
uh of infinity and Marvel Comics so this
like predates the modern day idea of the
inhuman Terrigen mists spreading
throughout the world now how that
happened is the question the question is
that if all these people are inhuman now
and if all these people derive their
powers from the Terrigen mists then who
was it that spread the mists throughout
the world and that's when we start to
realize the idea that like crystal for
example is starting to develop her
inhuman powers that these various people
who are who are here are are manifesting
their abilities and who knows what form
they're going to take but the question
this ass is was it Maximus the mad who
set this off you know basically the the
insane brother of Black Bolt and the
initial response of Medusa is that's not
possible one his bomb was destroyed and
to Maximus the mad is dead and so
there's no reason to believe that he's
the one responsible for all this and so
at this point we jump back to Bruce
Banner to the Incredible Hulk and this
is cool because once we get into this
situation initially it's Clea and Loki
who are kind of like cool the days 1
we're finished here like everything is
fine and then suddenly they're met with
the return of the Incredible Hulk
alongside Thor who have really just kind
of brought themselves back out of the
realm of mysteries death by quite
literally pulling on the rope that they
used to enter in the first place kind of
that tether that was offered there but
where Clea is overpowered by the forces
of like for and The Incredible Hulk she
starts calling up
loke who basically bailed and that's the
crazy thing about this loki is never a
reliable or trustworthy character in
Marvel Comics he never has been and he
never will be there's been times where
he's tried to do good things but by and
large with the exception of the most
recent run by Jason Aaron Loki has
always been a deceptive character he's
always been the master of trickster and
lies and so it's cool because basically
Clea got what everybody knew she was
going to get which was left hanging and
so where she basically says look if this
is how things are gonna be then fine
I'll just destroy it all I'll literally
obliterate the earth I'll leave and go
do whatever Thor turns around and beat
you to death with a hammer and that's
the end of Clea and so from here we pick
up with Captain America where he
actually transitions to Russia and it's
kind of interesting because when he's
there we find out this is where Colossus
went to after the the fall of the x-men
the death of Charles Xavier when whoever
was left as part of the x-men team
disbanded that he returned back to
Russia went back home and he's been one
of the many people who's been fighting
on this front of making sure that like
all the resources that are available are
gathered as they need to be and they're
basically sent across the world to the
places that need them so they kind of
like this massive resource for food and
supplies the issue is that when Captain
America shows up he says look the skull
is a kid the skull attacking New York is
a kid I'm mustering as many forces as I
can the actor you can see what we do in
order to try to bring as many people
under my belt as I possibly can and
where Colossus says no Captain America
again reiterate he says look this is a
kid and he looks at the world through a
kid's perspective he doesn't see all the
ends he sees the world in black and
white he doesn't see all the shades of
grey it's kind of a wild scenario in the
middle of all this the group suddenly
attacked by like Nick Fury and what we
find out is that Nick Fury's life model
decoys have been routinely showing up an
attacking Peter they've been been
consistently showing up and like trying
to take these guys out because their
program is basically just starting to go
awry it's really it's really cool and
it's really fascinating to show like
these other parts of the world but again
pick you back up with Mayday where she
goes and basically fights Iron Maiden
who's you know kind of being controlled
by by Red Skull or I'm sorry Wyatt by
school at least it seems like it is
ultimately she's able to get the upper
hand and actually able to get to defeat
she's actually able to defeat the iron
maiden and call it a day just by kind of
you know covering her face and webbing
and essentially cutting off her oxygen
supply and knocking her out accordingly
but once she shows up and goes to
confront the skull she learns the lesson
that all inexperienced superheroes do
just because you can fight
does it mean you should find a battle
when Mayday shows up and she lands in
front of the skull with the intention of
taking him out she can't move she can't
do anything and the skull says actually
you're in love with me and just
dominates her and that's where people
begin to just kind of give up and call
it a day it's really like everything's
basically lost here and so the skull
shows up to that to the to the brilliant
of residence of president Norman Osborn
and simply says like your reign is over
we're gonna throw you out that window
you're gonna die and I'm gonna become
the new President of the United States
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to Commerce explain make sure
you guys have the sub button did he come
part of the rob cork if you guys enjoy
this video make sure you drop a like and
yeah I love our sex love the earth X
line of stories it's so cool anyway guys
we're gonna bring this to an end and I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]